Ludwig is a live streamer and a YouTuber
with three and a half million
subscribers and he's done the impossible
from being fired from three different
jobs moving out to California with
absolutely nothing to now having the
world record of most subscribers in a
month on Twitch beating out ninja making
over 1.4 million dollars a month it's
safe to say that Ludwig is one of a kind
well in this video we get an exclusive
inside look into Ludwig's business
Empire where he will reveal how he did
it and how much money he made along the
way so if you're interested in content
like this and want to see more like it
make sure to subscribe because we post a
brand new episode every single Sunday so
hit the button it's totally free and now
with that said let's begin first we have
to thank our sponsor ftxus and as some
of you have seen I've been using their
platform now for pretty much a year and
I've really enjoyed it I like the fact
that their fees are lower than the
competitors and you're able to buy and
sell crypto extremely easy with just a
few clicks all you got to do is
literally go on the platform type in
what you want to buy how much of it you
want to buy how often you want to buy it
swipe right you're done and you get free
crypto with every single trade you make
over ten dollars not only can you get
paid to invest on FTX but also it just
really helps support our podcast like
Graham mentioned they've helped us
produce episodes every single Sunday for
your guys's enjoyment it's your guys
jack not your guises what are you
talking about your guys I didn't say
your guys yes you did for your guys's
enjoyment no I didn't you're gonna look
back at this yeah don't worry about it
just use FTX with the link Down Below in
the description and also guys I had to
kick Graham out for this one because it
is exclusive information but they're
soon launching FTX stock so you can then
trade stocks crypto and nfts all on the
same platform from your phone it's gonna
be amazing definitely check them out
with that link Down Below in the
description thank you so much and also
wait no also it's your guys not you guys
I didn't say it no I didn't say you guys
welcome to the iced coffee hour I'm the
guest Ludwig here with hosts Jack and
Graham podcasts over two years so far
has made 550
000 uh no 266
000 and the podcast is with uh Graham
and Jack no no we agreed on Jack and
Graham we've always said Jack and Graham
haven't we that's Graham and Jack you I
actually wanted Graham and Jack you
wanted Jack and Graham it does sound
better the short the long it's got to be
short and long that's true well anyway
welcome to the podcast and we're in your
set today by the way I am Jacker like
graham cracker we'll work on it no crack
we don't need to work on it we plan on
meeting at 11 30. and we kind of
mentioned it yeah but Graham and I were
like oh we should go to a coffee shop
first we could plan out some questions
get everything straight and we decide
some random coffee shop we show up there
and right after we get our coffees
Graham's talking to a fan that like
recognized him and I'm like wait a
second there he is and you just walk
straight into the coffee shop apparently
you go all the time yeah that was just a
wild coincidence you guys picked a great
coffee shop yeah it's good stuff it's
good stuff I mean come on yeah I typed
in your area and I just typed in coffee
and I saw the coffee places some of them
didn't look good at all and there was a
Starbucks like I'm not going to
Starbucks but I found a random place
that looked so good with like really
unique uh drink options and I tried it
it is so good now this is like a seven
dollar coffee but but this is the best
coffee I think I've had it was good and
you just dried in man and yeah the funny
thing too is when you were there there
were probably 15 or so people in there
two of them recognized you yeah is that
like is that a common thing does that
happen often to you yeah yeah I get
recognized a good bit uh I mean it's
generally like everyone's pretty nice
the thing that they usually want is a
picture you know that's like the like
the end of the engagement it's like
initially it's like
you seem familiar
oh I know who you are now confirm by
asking
then greeting and then end it by asking
for a picture so that you can say you
have done this move on with your day and
I think that's generally how every
interaction goes I always have the
encounter where I'm just kind of like
sitting somewhere I'll look around and
someone kind of like looks you make eye
contact for a split second and I'm like
let me look back and they're always like
this
oh they're like comparing faces and then
we lock contact you're like
like that always but it's always they
have to confirm on the phone to be like
the embarrassment of being wrong
outweighs the pleasure of being right
but you know what I do is I never look
at them because like you can tell if
you're peripherals if they're looking at
you oh yeah I I make them do the work of
confirming and coming up to me I'll
never do the look because that's like an
invitation to come in and they need to
have that bravery on their own and you
mentioned I was watching a video when I
was researching you before this that you
used to have a password where people
would have to say this in order to prove
to you that they're like true fans yeah
yeah that's something PewDiePie did I
had a silly one it was like you are Giga
Chad super ripped awesome hot dude
something like that and they have to
tell me that and only one guy ever gave
me the password and the problem is when
people meet I don't know if you
experience the same thing when people
meet me uh they're very nervous
unnecessarily nervous I would say but I
think it's just very unexpected shock
met with like oh I have not planned for
this interaction and so they're always
very nervous and so when this guy was
telling me like my passcode he's like
you're like super tall and hot and I was
like I was like okay this is weird
he did the things wow and I was like you
just forget that you had told people
this no I remember I told people but in
my head when they would tell me they
would tell me in a way that was like we
had known each other for years but
obviously no one plans to meet me
because they don't know where I'm at and
so when it actually happens it came out
a lot weirder than I thought it would
yeah so I'm like all right let's just
cut that just come up to me we'll grab
the picture it's all good yeah yeah you
know so it's surprising yeah you're
actually six feet tall yeah you actually
are and here I'm not saying that I was
initially kind of like you know
questioning people round up I round up
to six feet yeah a lot of people they
say they're six feet but they're like
five nine five ten right but you when I
saw you you're actually as tall as I
kind of thought you would be yeah which
is yeah yeah I think it's a big thing
for streamers especially because you
have no idea how tall streamers are how
big streamers are because you always see
him behind the camera and the only thing
you have for reference is what's around
them in that frame and so every single
streamer deals with a joke of being
short and I probably wrote that joke
harder than most so everybody thinks I'm
short or comes in at least like thinking
that maybe I'm not as tall as I say I am
but yeah I'm I'm I'm tall as hell I got
a truck because my dream car it's a mini
truck it's called like a k truck it's a
Subaru Sandbar 1997. it's imported from
Japan oh my god dude hey you added a
front check I'm surprised you didn't see
that yeah you want to drive by this guy
yeah I noticed it I was trying not to
hit it with my suitcase how much was
that it was
5500 and then it costs about another
1800 to import so 7 300 total that's
safe to drive like I'd imagine there's
no is there an airbag in that thing yeah
there's an airbag yeah okay the things
that make it a little more dangerous is
that it's a right side car because it's
an import from Japan yeah so I'm driving
on the right which can be a little weird
and then it's also like uh like a
left-handed you know manual transmission
which can be a bit weird left-handed
manual yeah
but I but I drove it for the first time
from Long Beach
um and it felt fine like I you know it
doesn't go the quickest it goes about
70. uh but like I felt decently safe on
it I wasn't too worried I mean I'm sure
if I hit something it's just not this is
not a Tesla safety rating shit's a
[ __ ] tank hits a wall bang but you
know if I don't do that I should be fine
I've always yeah I've been curious left
hand uh Drive how difficult is that to
learn versus right I don't even for me
like I drive stick but I think left hand
really instantly because you know you're
not gear shifting especially in a car
like this I mean it's not like a sports
car where you're like you know having to
go first second third fourth fifth like
it's pretty slow and steady uh and you
just you just put it in the slot and you
know when it's right like you do the
same habits like do you wiggle in
neutral yeah it's all wiggle the gear
shifter neutral just make sure it's in
there uh so it's the same Vibe uh it's
just the other hand and what's your
inspiration behind all these weird modes
of Transport that you have like the
Vespa yeah why don't you just get like a
you know I feel like people in your
situation would buy like a Lambo or buy
something no I don't I can't see you in
Atlanta I can see it necessarily I could
see a model as plaid I could see that so
while I thought about getting like a
Tesla for a bit but I didn't get it
because everybody has a Tesla and and I
think I enjoy a sense of originality uh
and I hate sports cars like I would
never I would never blow money on a
sports car I would never blow money on
any like fashion brands I don't like
spending money there it makes me feel
like a like I once rented a Porsche 911
like
um do you call it 911 or do you call it
9-1-1
yeah every anytime someone says Porsche
911
okay all right
yeah 911 never forget yeah uh and it was
lime green and I was driving it around
like West Hollywood and I just felt like
a piece of [ __ ] driving by a bunch of
people were were homeless on the streets
and I'm in a Porsche at a stop sign you
know I just I I feel like it's too much
of a flex and then I also am way more
stressed driving it because it you know
I'm scared where I park it maybe someone
Nicks it maybe it gets broken into maybe
it's because it's so low I just hit a
curb or something and and now I just
have a 7 300 car that I think looks dope
that if it gets beat up I don't really
care yeah but my plan for it is I think
I'm gonna put a ton of money into it and
make it an EV whoa because I think or
you just want the originality I think
it'd be so sick yeah because it I think
the car looks dope and so I want to
paint it to match my Vespa and then I
want to make it an EV and then it would
probably be way better to drive yeah
that was something I was not expecting
we ran into you at a coffee shop yeah
and you're like oh yeah just follow me
there and you're in a Vespa yeah and a
cool looking one too is like some retro
style something or other right yeah it's
like a Chinese knockoff my girlfriend
got me but it's meant to look like the
style of a classic 80s vest but yeah uh
it's like a sick mint green color I got
it because I went to I went to Italy uh
and I just I rented a Vespa in Rome I
just like asked the concierge I was like
can you give me Vespa they just hooked
me up for like three days no license no
nothing and I just wrote it around and
it was so fun and uh and I've always had
a problem where I'm like uh a I bought
with a small AOE field and I will only
engage with humans who I'm physically
able to interact with in person and I'm
very bad at like messaging online but
the problem is I can only engage with
those I can physically walk to or if I
live with and the Vespas like unlocked
my radius because now I'm way more happy
to hop on the Vespa and drive 10 miles
than I was getting into a car which is
weird because it's very similar but the
Vespa is just like easier to get in and
I'm happier riding it and I feel like
annoyed if I have to drive safe driving
the Vespa yeah so yeah it's pretty safe
I feel good I don't know I feel like I
would worry about the safety of a Vespa
and I've I've wanted a Vespa for a
strong six years but I was never allowed
allowed to have one for my parents
because it's dangerous yeah so what I
did to circumvent that was I bought a
bike and threw a motor on it okay and of
course I mean I totally destroyed that
thing and it broke because I don't know
what I'm doing right but it was probably
a lot more dangerous than a Vespa but I
feel like I would just be worried about
the safety I don't know I think it
depends where you're at like where I'm
at it's it's not like downtown L.A and
so riding the Vesper around feels like
pretty safe to me uh and and I think you
get used to it after a while I mean it
certainly is more dangerous than a car
like just inherently but you don't feel
that because every day when you drive
you don't get injured and so after doing
that 100 times you're like oh I am in a
safe vehicle so I think I think your
brain tricks you but first off we have
to thank our sponsor Henson shaving now
I don't know about you guys but I'm a
hairy dude and in order to look my age I
need to shave nearly every day which is
why I am so happy that Henson shaving
reached out to sponsor of this video
Henson is a family-run Aerospace machine
shop that has brought Precision
Engineering to the Razer business the
razors have a precisely built handle
that securely holds the blade which is
very important in shaving since the
firmer the grip on the blade and the
shorter the extension the safer and
better the shave they sent over some of
their single blade Precision razors and
it was genuinely the smoothest shave
I've ever had in my whole life it's
fully metal and uses standard dual Edge
blades that you could buy practically
anywhere so no subscriptions no
proprietary blades and no planned
obsolescence so if you want to save some
money over the course of a year you're
only going to spend between three and
five dollars on shaving compared to some
of the other shaving companies that
charge you an arm and a leg so it's time
to say no to subscriptions and yes to a
razor that'll last you a lifetime
so save money and get the best shave of
your life when you visit
hensonshaving.com iced coffee there you
could pick the razor for you and then
you could use the code iced coffee to
get two years of free blades
complimentary just make sure to add them
to your cart that's 100 free blades when
you visit
henson.com iced coffee and use code iced
coffee at checkout thank you so much
Henson and back to the podcast so what
do you do for fun besides vespa's and
cool cars I ride my Vespa around outside
of that uh I I love watching Sunset I'm
a big Sunset Fiend I thought you're
about to say watch selling Sunset the
Netflix show no the real estate show I I
just literally go at sunset hour you
know and I'll either walk and do a
little hike or I'll just like stretch uh
and I'll just watch it go down and then
I I met a random Taiwanese dude and so
sometimes we catch up there because he
also likes watching sunsets and so we're
buds we hang out you plan that out or is
it just by chance literally just two
ships in the night Crossing and I don't
have any way to contact him because he's
like a 55 year old Taiwanese man it's
cool though but if we do cross we chat
for like an hour nothing about getting
his number if you chat for an hour you
would think this like how do I contact
you again I think it's cooler this way
really yeah this is like how you get to
do it back in the day what if he's just
socially awkward like he wants you to
reach out but just doesn't know how to
it's been so long he hasn't asked me he
probably isn't interested it's about
once every two weeks so you know maybe
next time maybe we've hung out about
four or five times maybe the next time
I'll slide the number in what is it
about watching the sunset is it just
calming is it what about it I think it's
grounding I think it's very easy to be
in your own world think about your own
game but it's really small every YouTube
channel small even Mr Beast is small in
the grand scheme of the world and how
it's moving and in a hundred years if
you look back is Mr B someone that
people talk about regularly probably not
and I think it's grounding to look at
the giant Sun that we spin around and it
makes me feel good why does it make you
feel better for me I feel like that
would make me feel insignificant that
everything I'm doing doesn't doesn't
matter nothing I do matters why am I
doing anything I think it helps humble
you and it helps make the things you do
less about the ego and about being the
biggest and the best but it still
matters that you help the lives of those
around you because that changes like all
of society for years and I think that's
the most important thing you can do is
uplift the people around you and so I
think I think that's still an important
thing it makes me feel good and I have
less of ego importance put into I have
hit three and a half million subscribers
wow uh because that doesn't matter let's
talk a little bit more I've talked about
this a lot but feel like we kind of have
to visit it since this is a finance and
business oriented podcast the YouTube
acquisition type thing right what was
that process like to get acquired by
YouTube from twitch I know that you kind
of had a relationship with twitch since
you I mean you've been on there for an
extreme long time was that hard to
disband from twitch to go to YouTube and
what was your reasoning to switch from
twitch to YouTube yeah I think the dream
for every Creator is to eventually be a
big enough creator that you can leverage
that and then fish a deal from all the
major players which now is Facebook
YouTube and twitch and then try to get
the best one for your livelihood uh and
for me I was like okay I've reached uh
status as a big enough creator that I
can try to get one of these deals after
my original partner contract ended uh so
let's do it and the goal was to just get
a deal from Facebook and YouTube so I
could leverage it for a better twitch
deal that was what I was thinking going
in because I was like I'm a twitch
streamer through and through I'm not
leaving twitch why would I do that uh
and and so we started uh and you know we
had like a like a verbal Facebook offer
and and a YouTube offer but when I was
actually in the negotiations I started
to shift how I was thinking about it
um because the the twitch people were
just a lot
they weren't like the people who I
specifically talked to were very nice
but they were a lot less
um caring about like what I was trying
to do and the goals I had and trying to
accomplish that and it was much more I
am a gear in the system that makes
twitch run they need me to stream this
amount of hours which gives them this
much money and they give me this much of
a cut of that amount of money and then
okay good job tap me on the ass get the
next person in line and so you're very
replaceable on Twitch which I don't
think they're wrong to think that
because throughout the whole mixer thing
turns out that people are very
replaceable Twitches still has the
biggest market share you know but when
you get when you when you feel like that
it feels a lot worse and YouTube I mean
they make you feel like you're you're
having drinks with your buds at the
table uh and so talking with them more
and more I started to feel better about
it but I was still very much leaning
twitch up until the very end I don't
know if uh you know like the whole coin
flip story I like that story a lot yeah
can you explain this yeah so like I I
was even though I had a much better deal
from YouTube it was it was not like
double the amount of money but it was
pretty close like it was it was pretty
close to double the amount of money
twitch off it I was still leaning
towards twitch uh and I went into a call
with the YouTube guys and you know we
had shared a lot of time we'd gone on
lunches all that good stuff and I was
like hey you know it's nothing you guys
did wrong you guys fought really hard
and I think you guys did really well and
I love what you're doing with YouTube
but I'm going with twitch and they were
like
and they hit me with the last second
offer that was that was just like a 20
bump and I was like wow that's like
crazy
so I thought long and hard and the
original reason that I told them I
wasn't going with them and I and I
didn't let them know right there is that
I had flipped a coin and heads was
twitch Tails was YouTube uh and it had
gone with heads because I just I
couldn't make the decision and a lot of
the times in my life I like to leave it
to chance and and somehow that ended up
as an insane negotiating tactic of me
walking and they were like nah stay uh
and so then I thought I'd do the same
thing to Twitch which is like hey let's
hop in the call I'm gonna tell you I'm
gonna leave and then they were just like
have fun and you know they have the next
creator online they have to worry about
which again no flame to them that's how
their business runs I like the coin flip
thing Jack knows I'm I yeah I believe
that whatever's meant to be is gonna
happen so I like to leave it up to fate
you call it chance I just say you know
then it's destined to happen it's out of
my control and this was meant to go in
this direction so I flip coins or I flip
my phone yeah so I'm like you know if it
lands at this it's heads and then this
is Tails and I'll flip my phone half the
time that makes the decision for me yeah
and it's never led me astray and for you
even when you flip the coin I mean that
coin flip ended up making you so much
more and getting you to where you are
today if it wasn't for that coin flip or
if it just had landed on YouTube you
would have just done it anyway and uh
left some extra money on the table Yeah
if it was just YouTube out it just had a
worse deal overall yeah which is funny
to think about yeah I'm not as
deterministic and Destiny focused but I
know that any path you take in life it
will work out because it just has to The
World Keeps spinning your life keeps
moving on everything has to work out
there's no other choice
um and so it's like whatever decision
you make you just have to be happy with
it and uh and I think that's why I was
okay with the flip do you think that
twitch's unwillingness to fight for
their creators is going to come back and
bite them in the butt at some point in
the future and are you bullish on Twitch
as a platform for the you know to have
longevity or do you think YouTube's
gonna dominate because I have friends
that stream as well like more casually
but they say that it seems like twitch
is like kind of falling apart and it's
mostly internal stuff that that's
causing that yeah I think the not paying
for creators is honestly a decent
decision that they've made internally to
try to become profitable I think what's
going to screw them over and to be clear
I think they're going to have market
share for the next five years but I
think five years from now they're gonna
be a bit screwed because of every single
decision they've made I don't think any
product they have released has really
helped them grow and they really lucked
out by doubling in size because of kovid
without that I think they'd be in a
really bad spot I think kovitz saved
their asses because every product they
make is extracting value out of the
people that already watch them rather
than growing and YouTube already dwarfs
them in terms of people on the platform
so it's like just a matter of time I
think for YouTube to catch up in terms
of the basic products that people expect
watching a live stream you know like a
like a better functioning chat a culture
of emotes
um and all that stuff YouTube will get
that they're slow because they're about
a company and then it'll be a lot harder
and I think what also might screw them
over is I I know there's an internal
pressure to become profitable because
they're just tanking money and I feel
like they might eventually remove twitch
Prime
which is a huge driver in revenue for
creators uh so I think if that day comes
that's when the Turning that's going to
be the turning point it seems like
twitch makes the Creator compete with
them as a platform rather than really
boosting them up because I know they
also have that like their TOS as far as
Banning goes is pretty like it's not
very stable and I know people have been
banned for like really simple things and
kind of honest mistakes and then other
people haven't been banned or you know
temporary shorts who is the one that uh
you know had I was doing stuff yeah they
were doing doing stuff on the live
stream we want to say would be familiar
with that stuff doing stuff like you
know like uh well the one who's getting
railed doggy style yeah yeah I didn't
want to say that but uh yeah text Grammy
you just got to be yeah I'm saying hey
it's okay Susan you should have seen it
bro but yeah but uh yeah so what that
was a suspension and then brought right
back but other people yeah right she was
having actual intercourse yes yeah
explain to your grandma so she
understands I think I'm intercourse yeah
yeah Grandma you know like doggy you've
been there we all been there
uh no I like leave that in PR wise
twitch has just had a detrimental past
year and a half part of it is all the
products they release and then part of
it is just a failure to adhere to like a
terms of service that people like
generally align with their morals uh and
so like yeah someone had sex on stream
and they were banned for seven days and
they were back uh and then just
yesterday somebody got banned for 30
days uh a pretty well liked Creator
because someone in chat was like like
roasting them being mean to them and
then they said I'm going to fight you at
twitchcon this is not a joke as a joke
which you know because obviously they're
not gonna go to Twitter that's a joke
yeah but they said that and then they
gave them a 30-day ban which look I'm
not against Banning someone for
threatening physical harm to somebody
else even if it's an anonymous stranger
online but 30 days in relative relative
to a seven day ban for actually having
sex seems weird to most people uh and
and I think that problem always comes up
uh and it's just a PR thing because like
look the same problem exists in the NFL
like the NFL has varying bands of of
weeks to months and it none of it lines
up like people get banned for smoking
weed for two months and then there was
like um what's his name who assaulted
like 30 women in a massage parlors have
you heard of this I haven't he's one of
the highest paid quarterbacks in the
league and he was originally just
suspended with pay for like four weeks
for assaulting about 30 women at massage
parlors coercing them just no it was
just uh I think it was like a civil case
and settled out uh but it was just like
he had coerced them into doing sexual
favors after asking them for just
massages uh and it's like he got
suspended less along than people smoke
weed but the NFL is very easily able
with their PR team to just show that
aside sure and then twitch doesn't you
know uh twitch is is held accountable
and then probably overly roasted for the
bad decisions they make uh and they've
never been able to get behind that yikes
I think another issue with twitch is
discoverability and it seems as though
that the people on the top stay at the
top because they're the ones that get
pushed versus everyone else the
algorithm's not there to find new
creators who are up and coming unless
you already know of them yeah yeah
there's a this is a real quote from the
CEO he had said this in a private
meeting and I I had found out about this
he said the best way to grow on Twitch
is to grow on another platform and then
bring the audience over to Twitch which
is just a failure of the platform
and I discovered recently that I don't
know how to stream on YouTube I just
figured it out this week because the
entire time for the first eight months
I'd been streaming as if I was on Twitch
and the way that you stream on Twitch is
you just have the most viewers in a
certain game category and then you stay
live for a really long time because
you'll build up a lot of dead viewers
people who just have you on their second
monitor they leave to work they go to
bed whatever and then you'll stay higher
in the category and then people always
click whatever's at the top of of their
favorite category whether it's just
chatting a video game like League of
Legends or valorant or whatever it is
and you just grow and grow and grow it
doesn't work like that on YouTube or
Tick Tock there's no categories you
don't go to a game you like and then
watch who's playing that game you are
fed the stream based off what the
algorithm thinks you will like and so
it's much more important for to create
um a stream that has really good watch
time and has a sense of urgency that
makes people stick around because the
better the watch time the more people
will will stay and the more it'll get
recommended which doesn't exist on
switch and I just figured that out this
week because I started doing streams
that are like I have one hour to beat
this game uh and I play like Minecraft
and I have a timer on screen and the
closer I get to the hour the more the
viewership goes up uh and I and I ended
up with streams I would get like thirty
thousand forty thousand viewers
um because it just gets pushed and
pushed and pushed because people will
stick around waiting for it to reach an
hour as opposed to Twitch you're better
off streaming 20 hours straight like xqc
or train wrecks do yeah Lily Pichu is
doing that now I see her yeah she'll be
streaming for like 12 hours straight
yeah that's not good for YouTube nuts
but I have to also say so I had a
channel well we had a channel it's
called Millennial money where we went
live and we did that for about a year
and a half and then we talked to someone
who is a rep at YouTube who said that if
you just film this ahead of time and
post it as a video it's going to do
better than alive and we did and
instantaneously from going from live to
just pre-recording something like this
and posting it our views doubled yeah so
I think there's something there that
YouTube isn't quite pushing live streams
and for some reason people don't seem as
willing to click on a live stream that
would was like a day old because it's
like oh it's not live anymore versus if
it's just pre-recorded how do you
approach that do you have to go live or
is it something where you could just
film something I guess it's less fun for
for your audience because they're
accustomed to that yeah so so my
original strategy which was a new
strategy when I was streaming on Twitch
is every stream would have segments that
would become YouTube videos I'm not just
streaming for the sake of being live and
playing a game I have a specific thing
like I'm going to give my credit card to
stream to buy anything they want on
Amazon for a couple hours that'll turn
into a YouTube video and that worked
when I was on Twitch because there are
people who like watching live streams
there are people who like watching
YouTube videos it's separate when I went
to YouTube I recognized pretty quickly
that the watch time that that I would
get from viewers was way lower like they
would stick around for like seven ten
minutes then they'd leave because I'm
competing with other videos like in the
sidebar there's like a juicy veritasium
video that's gonna make you feel like a
genius for 10 minutes or it's my dumbest
playing Mario you know so it's like the
competition is way way fiercer and so
it's important that for a good YouTube
video you need like like an intro you
need a specific goal and you need Stakes
right those are all important things to
YouTube video and then the thing that
you need for a live stream is a sense of
urgency
because the thing that a live stream has
as an advantage you can think of it when
you think of like a like a professional
sports game like a basketball game is
the ability to be there for the moment
say I was here and you lose that when
you watch the video that's why you know
like highlights are way less popular
than watching the game itself like
that's the cultural moment so you need a
sense of urgency in a live stream that
make it feel like it was worth the time
to watch in a moment that makes it that
you can say you were there for how do
you come up with these ideas
like what to do on stream so like the
the idea of like the urgency or like
like that concept or like specifically
what I'm doing specifically what you're
doing because it seems like you have
multiple segments sometimes you'll
you'll do one thing over the other how
do you pick so frequently what you think
will do well I spend a couple hours
every day and I'll just watch streamers
like the way I watch streams is like I
click on summit1g I watch them for three
minutes then I click on lyric maybe he's
doing something cool he's playing a cool
new game watch him for a few more
minutes should I try that game and maybe
not it's a little more Niche he's a
little different of a Creator all right
what's Miss gift doing what's xqc doing
and I click on every Creator who I think
does things well and who might push the
meta of what is being streamed and what
is being consumed and see what maybe I
could try doing uh and if I don't find
inspiration there then maybe I look at
YouTube videos or maybe what I was doing
six months ago because you know what I
was doing six months ago probably will
work now if I just spin it a little bit
uh and I try to think that day of what
I'll do you and it's pretty much on an
everyday cycle like I know what I'm
doing uh like at 4 P.M at 2PM that same
day and I don't know like any any time
before that what if you have no idea if
I have zero idea sometimes I just won't
go live at all like I will like that
period of time that I'm saying is 12 to
2 p.m might go from 12 to 5 p.m or 6 p.m
uh and it can feel sometimes like I'm
not even working because I'm just
actually just watching streams and just
trying to think of things maybe I just
get some air ride my Vespa go somewhere
and try to come back and I will either
make a decision to just not do anything
and then maybe I'll make a mogul mail
I'll do an offline recording for
something else I'll work somewhere else
uh or I'll just go live and I'll just be
like hey I got nothing to do today
maybe we can just like watch this video
play this random game and just like at
least still give a stream to the people
who look forward to streams as content
for their day how do you find
inspiration and how do you stay
productive like wouldn't it be easy to
get distracted if you're just watching
People's streams and then maybe
extending that three minute period to a
30 minute period oh yeah dude like I
pretend that I'm working when I'm
watching tick tocks because it's like oh
I'll like the tick tocks and watch them
later on stream but it's like no but
sometimes for 90 minutes I always have
the goal of of trying to accomplish
something that day so I feel
accomplished if I do a stream or if I
record a video offline or if I'm working
on on uh something business related in a
profound way so as long as I'm able to
accomplish one of those and I and I know
the deadline is when the day is over
um I'll still feel like I've done
something uh and in the greatest way
that I'm able to at least get something
out is just the good old yoink and twist
so like if if I'm really out of options
like I can just take something I've done
and twist it up a little bit and and it
usually will do well if it did well in
the past sure tell us about this credit
card spending on Amazon how does that
work that was an idea I had because
sodapoppin used to do this concept where
random people would link him items and
he would just buy them and I was like
that's cool but what if I had like a
time limit and I allowed them to buy
anything they wanted and they would vote
on whether they buy it or not with an
item limit you know so it's like you
guys can only buy 10 items you have an
hour to do it I will I will purchase
everything you link me things and then
I'll just click on them and then you
vote Yes or no and it's interesting to
see like like some people will buy
really expensive things some people will
try to buy like a 100 gallon bottle of
lube or something just because they
think it's funny and uh and so I've done
that series probably like six or seven
times in slightly different ways how did
they vote on it do you just see like yes
or no's in the chat yeah just run a poll
I run a poll I see simple poll yes or
no's 51 I get it 51 knows I don't get it
what's the weirdest thing that you think
you've bought from that yeah I bought
insane I bought a 16 000 statue of
Jackie Chan what'd you do with it it's
just in my stream room he's just there
he terrifies people when they walk in
because no one expects sixteen thousand
dollars it's like a Madame Tussauds
level like no wax figure like it looks
very accurate and it feels a bit like
skin like it's a little Jackie Chan it's
like silicone yeah yeah and it looks
like Jackie Chan how bummed were you
when they picked a sixteen thousand
dollar like item that has no utility
yeah I I think I think it's funny like I
I don't cool with it I don't like
spending money again like on fancy cars
or fancy clothes but I don't care how
much I will spend on on videos and
content I because it feels like it's
productive in a way is there ever a
desire to return it the next day that's
like get it and then think ah let me let
me refund this let me send it back the
only time that I really hate it is when
it's something that I just really can't
use like they bought a eighteen hundred
dollar water bubbler like the ones you
would see at a school or a office
building it was a water bubbler uh like
a water fountain like the ones where you
like you click it like an echo and then
the water comes out from the spout I
don't know what you guys call them you
call them water bubblers East Coast
water fountain yeah sure okay yeah
waterfront's probably West Coast
terminology okay but yeah just one of
those water fountains and it's 1800 and
I just can't install it like I don't
have a plumbing for this I can't attach
this to the wall so it's just useless
and I just ended up donating it to like
some um school because I I I can't do
anything with it yeah so I I'm only
annoyed when I have something that I
feel like I cannot use in a way that's
entertaining what about everything else
that you can't use like you're talking
about just random items do you keep them
no we end up usually trying to donate
what we can and then it's a lot of waste
uh of just you know I have
just a stupid amount of random statues
and knickknacks and like desk ornaments
that that I just cannot keep all of them
uh and so I've done there's three ways I
get rid of them one is I just straight
up donate it so who will take it the
other is I've done like charity auctions
and I've sold on stream for charity the
items I've gotten in the past uh and
then people will buy it and then the
third is I just have to trash it well
before you trash it Jack will take it
yeah well I don't know about that 100
gallons of lube Jack I would take the
Jackie Chan if you ever get rid of it I
think it's so funny Shaggy's awesome
yeah you guys will see him he's
terrifying when you walk in yeah there
was a really cool uh it was a movie prop
so you could go on websites and find
these really realistic like alien movie
props but there was like a big scary
16-foot Yeti that was so cool looking I
wanted that for the living room a 16
foot 16 feet 16 feet it's tall yes how
are you gonna get that through the food
this is the back door yeah you got six I
would put vaulted ceilings yeah in Vegas
Vegas are 22 foot ceilings I guess that
is the Vegas thing right having those
giant vaulted ceilings yeah the craziest
thing I wanted to buy that I was so
close to buying uh and I should have
bought it was it's it's called the
Timothy Olton Apollo and it's a replica
of the uh one of the Apollo spacecrafts
or whatever and inside of it was uh like
a sitting area so it's like a like a
circular thing with a table in the
middle and they're so unbelievably cool
and I thought I could put that in the
living room and it looks like a
spaceship and we could film a podcast in
there how much was it 150 Grand but I
could write it off because it would be
for the podcast true yeah but it just
happened to sit in the living room now I
think these things would have been way
more because this was in covet yeah
because this was uh in like the worst of
covid where everyone was like just
panicking didn't know what was going to
happen with the economy and they
discounted this thing I think normally
it was like 200 grand for these things
uh and they discounted it and I
explained like here's who I am here's
how it would be used I think they only
made like 10 of them what do they make
them for uh decoration oh just you sell
them to sell them yeah but they're like
seating arrangements inside of it so
it's purposely there's supposed to be a
utility with it too yeah I couldn't
imagine how big that would be it's huge
yeah but there are things like that that
I see that I'm like man I I would love
to do that there's a thing it's a 700
flashlight I saw it on Tick Tock I have
10 of those you have ten are you serious
it's the uh the illumin yep uh r18 or
whatever yes I got a bunch to see how
many it would take to cook an egg that's
a genius idea and how many did it take
two so you didn't need eight I did it
because I thought stupidly you get eight
and then everyone stands around and they
just point to add the egg but what you
actually do is you put one flashlight
underneath and then one on top and it
becomes like a convection oven so I know
you have a relationship with Mr Beast Mr
Bean pretty good one you were in one of
his videos three oh yeah I saw the plane
video right I've done three videos one's
been posted on his channel one he didn't
post so I stole and then the final one
hasn't been uploaded yet okay yeah see I
only saw the uh yeah the plain one the
plane I knew the one he posted on your
channel but I didn't know if that like
right yeah maybe it doesn't count yeah
but what was that like because for those
that don't know Mr Beast basically made
a full-on video how much money did he
spend on that yeah so the first time he
ever asked me to do a video was like a
1.1 million dollar shoot that involves
like two people military guys doing a
bunch of obstacles biggest sumo wrestler
in the world giant obstacles whatever it
was uh and and I went out there to
record to be basically a backup host for
him because it was a race he would not
be able to beat it get to the next
obstacle sometimes if there are going
faster than them so I would just be
there in case to explain what to do and
that was why he asked me to go out there
and I had met him before this just to
hang out uh and and I think he thought I
was funny and I would do well and and so
we do it all finished recording a couple
things go wrong in it like there's a few
hiccups and uh and so I'm waiting for to
get for it to get uploaded hit him up
like every week I'm like it wasn't going
up I'm curious what's going on he's like
I don't know I don't know and then one
time
um I hit him up I'm like what's it going
up he's like I'm not uploading it like
what you spent 1.1 million dollars he's
like yeah I didn't like it it's not good
was he that matter of fact about it or
was he like depressed at all or no he's
when he makes a decision it just is what
it is and and like he's the person who
makes that call too right it's not like
somebody above him he's like you know
Jimmy I don't think this is the one it's
him who's like we're not uploading it
and everybody else who's worked on it
for months like
oh dude but but like that's his thing
and I think he almost takes pride in the
fact that he spends money on things that
don't go out because it shows how much
he cares and how much he's willing to
put into YouTube where most creators
wouldn't so he just scrapped it and then
we did a podcast with him when I was
filming a second video
um with him and and just as a joke I was
like well if you're not uploading it let
me upload it on my channel he was like
yeah that'd be funny
because he wanted my most viewed video
to be his video and now it is my most
viewed video it's just his video it's
just his videos his thumbnail too yeah
thumbnail his title his video I did it I
did I did two intros I'm in it for about
30 seconds I remember clicking on your
video and being so thrown off that like
I thought it was a Mr Beast video at
first but I saw you uploaded wasn't it
like I stole was it how much a million
dollars for Mr Beast that was my
explanation of it but the actual video
is called I buried a hundred thousand
dollars go find it yep and it's I and
it's Mr Beast in the thumbnail and it's
my channel yeah do you think it could
have done better because I honestly
didn't know about you too well when I
when I scrolled across that video for
the first time but changing your profile
picture and channel name to Mr Beast
when you post it and then you post it as
him because that would have been
hilarious click on it had I known it was
an actual Mr Beast don't you lose your
verification when you change your name
you would have gotten it back yeah but
yeah I think it would have and I think
part of it was an expense experiment
like he was curious because he's always
had the idea that YouTube is all skill
not luck and with the knowledge he has
if he had to start a channel from Ground
Zero it would just Skyrocket upwards and
so this is like okay let's find out uh
and I think there's definitely an
element to a video being really good
having great click-through rate and
great watch time but also it helps if
the video is uploaded on a Channel with
100 million subscribers and has just a
guaranteed Bedrock of viewership
um so I think like if this video is on
his channel it certainly would have
gotten 40 million views at least and on
my channel it's sitting about like seven
and a half I agree with that I probably
would have been more compelled as if you
were to click on it just because you
know what he didn't like about the video
because I saw it I didn't think there
was anything wrong with it yeah there's
a couple things that went wrong like the
first problem uh was they had a giant
Target that they were supposed to shoot
like a bullseye with a cannon and the
target's ripped because it was Outdoors
it was just vinyl it's huge vinyl
targets they just tripped both of them
and then then they're like okay backup
will shoot the car with a cannon and
then the Cannonball just turned out to
be super flimsy in the wind barely moved
at all so that just looked kind of bad
like that segment whatever one segment
move on there's another segment they're
supposed to wrestle a a Japanese the
heaviest Japanese sumo wrestler uh
they're supposed to like do a Sumo a
match against them they both end up
because he has the coordinates tucked in
his side just running up grabbing it and
leaving it and you can hear the Japanese
sumo wrestling Japanese after he goes
have he started so it's like just kind
of lackluster and then the ending they
just sprinted to the end before anyone
was really there so it's like
I think the day of the shooting felt a
lot worse than what the final product
ended up being but it's hard to detach
that feeling from what it looked like at
the very end yeah he's got an
interesting business model with his main
Channel it seems like that's the Lost
leader like that's the Costco chicken
that's in front that gets people through
to then watches other channels like his
gaming channel he was talking about
makes so much and then the reacts
Channel
um and if he wanted to he could just
post reacts videos all the time and just
print money I mean that's got to be
mostly profit right but the main Channel
yeah he's very uh up front that he loses
money in a lot of those videos and I
think Costco is a good example because I
think he's just as prideful of it being
a loss leader yeah I think he's like he
loves that he is like I've spent like 10
million dollars on videos in the past
two months and I've thrown away half of
half of them it's like he loves that
because I think it gives him a sense of
Pride yeah it is astounding though he's
not exaggerating that he does spend
everything yes it there's I don't know I
was trying to calculate in my mind like
here's how much he makes here's how much
he spends ends it all gets reinvested it
is amazing to me how little he's taken
out for himself and just everything is
back into the videos and just making
good and he's he's that serious about
I'm like all right you know Mr B's just
okay really it's not just about making
the best videos right he's like no it's
the best videos that's all I want to do
it's incredible I would love to see you
do that again would you try another
Channel and see if you could replicate
that once more I think it's too hard to
completely isolate all the variables in
that sort of experiment and I think the
idea of skill.luck is interesting and
fun and people love exploring that
so I I am working on that but rather
than do it through a video that I make
I'm working directly with a Creator and
I have been for a while now
um because remember that Mr Beast tweet
and it's like I worked this Creator this
is the before of how much they made this
is the after I was like that's crazy so
I I thought I would try the same and
it's been going pretty well and you
can't say what creators no leaks because
then it'll kind of say yeah how does
that yeah how does that work how did you
find the Creator do you do you take a
split in terms of now if you is it just
a test purely just like I am trying to
Mentor this person and you know at first
we would have like scheduled calls and
it's been going on long enough now that
they know what they're doing
um and they're I think they're
incredible at it uh and and I want no
ownership of it and and I keep telling
them if the thing that comes out of this
is you have grown and I don't even get a
video out of it I'm happier than if I
get a video uh and you haven't grown you
know what I mean yeah so I'm I'm just
mostly focused on on that yeah sometimes
I'll notice people and I think they're
going to be successful no matter what
happens if I'm helping or if I'm not
you're gonna do well and sometimes some
people that you come across just have
whatever that might be and you're like
oh no Jack Gordon is a great example I
found his channel so early on I'm like
oh my gosh uh he's like a a young Vsauce
and uh you know what I think I can't
remember if I I think I made him an
offer to come work with me in the very
beginning oh yeah yeah I did I thought
it would be so cool because then we'd
have two Jacks we'd have one Jack and
then Jack Gordon and I I thought it was
a long shot he'd even take the offer
he's and he didn't but I was I wasn't
even surprised I'm like no it's his
Channel's gonna blow up and sure enough
it did yeah but he just had some yeah uh
he's at 350 now but he's in high school
oh and uh he barely ever posts oh really
yeah you still post every now and then
but I'm like if you just quit High
School cool and just posted one video
every other week you would be he would
be at a million subscribers within like
a few months I remember I think I was it
was vid Summit last year I was there and
I was at an event there and some lady
came up to me and she started talking to
me turns out it was his mom yep and she
was like yeah like I don't want him to
drop out of high school or I don't want
him to like pursue this because he needs
to pursue his education and stuff like
that I just thought he was but he's but
he's an example he'll do well whatever
he sets his mind to like if he wants to
be a marine biologist he'll be the best
Marine buyer he's she's just got that
mind that's great but he's also good on
camera just a focused person who's
charismatic yeah what's the most
expensive thing you've bought uh
probably the Ford GT but that was an
investment everything I bought was like
that car was actually better than the s
p 500s it's it's almost as good as some
of the best real estate deals I've done
why what what is the goal with the money
why are you the dragon who Hoards the
gold I don't think I I don't think it's
a dragon reports it's uh I just enjoy it
I like I like being through like
business I understand being Frugal and
not spending but
for me when I hit a million dollars I'm
like I'm good this is all I need any
amount More Than This outside of a house
I will say uh is not necessary for my
day-to-day to function and if I had more
I wouldn't know what to do with it and I
would rather I don't I don't need that
which is why I have a lot of overhead as
opposed to you who doesn't have a lot of
overhead but has way more money than me
so it's like what what do you see I love
investing I love personal finance I love
finding a deal I I take so much
enjoyment and and finding an undervalued
whatever it might be and investing in it
so I I take a lot of Pride and and
finding something that maybe other
people didn't see and for me like the
Ford GT was something like I think these
are gonna be half a million dollar cars
this is a good deal I set a price like I
found the car worked out so everything I
do is is kind of focused around that but
then I also I only want to spend like
two percent of what I have invested and
then that way it's sustainable so that
no matter what happens I'm always living
off of two percent of whatever the total
is but that means also that let's say
you know you make a million dollars you
invest a million dollars well that's now
an extra twenty thousand dollars a year
that I could spend guilt-free because I
know no matter what happens it's going
to be coming back right to be fair like
I respect the fact that you are so
Thrifty to the extent of like actually
probably helping the environment because
we'll go out and he'll like save the
ketchup package but it's still on record
saying he makes like six million or
whatever in a year but still at the same
point saving ketchup packets but here's
the thing but I don't want them to go to
waste so I'm very much like if I waste
anything like this cup for instance I'll
keep the cup wash it out so I could
reuse it again
but stuff like that it's just like
because they don't want to waste the cup
it's a plastic it's a plastic cup I
don't reuses them Macy hates that I
rinse them I rinse them yeah she's she's
you don't use toilet paper because it's
wasteful
what do you use it's not a hand what you
could just wash it in the sink water's
cheaper than toilet paper so you just
what do you mean you why what do you
mean you give them a bidet no that's
expensive what you need to get a bidet
I'm kidding no you don't put his hand
man no Jack's made that up that was a
joke in France
no they don't yeah because the bidets
are separate attachments from the main
unit so you have to get up after
[ __ ] and then you go over to the
other bidet and then you turn it on and
then just use your hands wait what you
just use your hand to clean your ass I
mean like you would in the shower
I don't know I don't know okay that's
that's too far yeah yeah I thought you
might have had a little French in you
you didn't know you had that dog I have
a attached bidet so it's like uh it's
like a uh that's actually something I'm
about to drop is I just made my own
bidet
because I love bidets do you have one no
do you have one you know what everyone
who has one swears by them yeah no I've
I've tried one one or two times I don't
like them what did you use there was one
in a hotel that's why this is a heated
seat two different types of oscillating
sprays heated water okay five different
pressure levels it has a deodorizer for
when you're using it you need that all
right it also has a self-regulated
energy saving and dryer if you don't
want to use TP but I mean I still use TP
but what you do is is is uh I've been
working on this for like a year now of
making this bidet and I've made two one
that's probably similar to the hotel
like a everyday 50 unit and then one
that's like the 500 souped up unit uh
and I think it's just a total life
changer so what about B days are you so
fast
what about bidets really enamors you I
think it's the correct way hygienically
probably to go to the bathroom like how
is it better it's just it's just like
it's like you asking me it's like why
are we showering and not just using more
deodorant like that's what it feels like
it's like you are taking a poop and then
just using dry paper and then just
pulling out some of it yeah like it's
like pulling out like Jack think about
this yeah hold on do you have a pet yeah
I do okay your pet your pet poops on a
carpet what are you just gonna grab
Bounty and then just rub it in and then
be like all right I've done it and then
walk away no I like to think my butt
isn't a carpet it is but it's not unless
you're waxing it is
and I unless you want to open up to this
podcast right now like Graham Graham
know what's going on down there what
what if you do wax does that make a
difference I think so yeah I actually
think if you wax it's just the it's just
the cleanest wipe uh it's probably still
better to have water right like just
hygienically
um
my friend got waxed for a podcast and he
was crying in pain really yeah because
he got everything I've been waxed on my
chest before yeah very very painful
right very painful anyway I'm gonna get
I'm gonna get you guys I'm gonna have
you try up a day okay and then you will
your lives will be changed so you're
selling a bidet you're turning this into
a to make money from it yeah I've made a
bidet it's been like a eight month
process I have a factory in Korea that
I've worked with and and we're about
ready to to sell them give us a price
point how much is that going to be it's
50 for the base level and then 500 for
the Primo why not anything in between
because there isn't much right like
there's the bidets that just directly
connect to the water line and that only
requires uh like a splitter and then you
just turn it on turn it off and then
there's the ones that require
electricity and and so there's not like
a way for that one to be cheaper it's a
bunch of electronics uh um
so it's like you'd just be making up
value couldn't there be a battery
operated one or one that you just plug
in and like charge
maybe but no one used that I think the
amount of electricity pull and the
amount of times you'd have to it's not
really something that exists in the
market okay I think there are versions
of the 500 ones that are cheaper but I
went with the one with all the all the
the gizmos and the gadgets so are you
taking like a like a is it like a white
label sort of product and kind of
switching it up a little bit or do you
developing from scratch or how it's kind
of similar to a yeah it's mostly a white
label project but we've customized it
because
um I feel like the largest bidet
manufacturer it's brondell uh and we've
worked with them to like
basically find the best thing we can
make and then have one that is still
affordable that yeah the thing looks
good you serious about selling the like
you want to take this in the direction
of like making money from this or is it
a side project for you I want to be like
the my pillow guy but for bidets and not
racist who's the my pillow he's like the
he's like the big Trumper who would sell
pillows they're like 60 pillows and he
was just hard course every Republican
would have like their pillows and you'd
see guys at rallies with their pillows
next to them but but like he's like
trying to revolutionize by having comfy
pillows I feel like everybody should use
bidets like I feel like that is the
correct thing and after using them most
people hate going back like if you go on
a trip your life is significantly worse
and so I want to bring bidets to America
it's already in most of Europe in in
Asia in the Middle East it's just
America it's very far behind why do you
think that is why are Americans not
embracing a bidet I think we're shy
about potty we're shy about bathroom
stuff you know like like I think I think
that's mostly it I think it's like we
don't we don't talk about it we don't
discuss it it probably doesn't do well
for marketing as well you know talking
about what you're gonna poop with so I'm
just trying to I'm trying to I'm trying
to start a movement all right so when
I'm done with all the streaming you know
how Mr B's got Beast Burger yeah this is
my Beast Burger okay Ludwig's bidets
it's called swipe wow that's a great
name that's pretty good you like that
yeah yeah you should incorporate
movement in like the the logo or the
slogan of the Box yeah it could be like
you know short for bowel movement like
you know the movement you need or like
something like that I don't know the
slogan is welcome to the 21st century
that's good yeah because I think that
you know toilet paper is that's stuff
can I connect to your iPhone though like
I feel like it should have some sort of
control of like a smartphone they have a
remote
specifically for the the toilet that you
you just connect to the wall huh and
then you pull it out okay that's the
whole thing how about this can we talk
about your relationship yeah yeah uh
when did you meet your girlfriend I met
her streaming I was live and she was
live because she was a streamer she
started the same time as I did and she
used to compete in these like I don't
know if you know like Austin show uh but
he used to do like these like dating
shows online kind of like reality TV
type stuff but for live streams what
Minx did yes that was the thing
yes okay yeah and uh and she would
compete on them and she would win a lot
because she was very good at like like
going above and beyond she's like a
baker so she would make cakes and stuff
for them uh and then she would Farm like
random
um guys in who are streaming for Content
so she'll just go to their streams and
be like be my chat's dad and then leave
and go to another person leave go to
another person that just came into my
stream one time and then I I was like no
I'm I'm a tier three sub to Pokeman and
we just joked around and then we
followed each other and we started
talking and uh and now we've been dating
eating for almost three years and how is
that balancing relationship while also
having a pretty rigorous work schedule
it helps that she's also a streamer
right because there's periods of time
where she's way busier than I am like
she's run events like the streamer
Awards uh that that have got more views
than me xqc or or like mizkiff I've ever
gotten uh and when she's working on that
she's gone the whole time so like I get
it when she has to do that and she gets
it when I do my stuff the only time that
there was ever a period where she was
like okay you this is way too much was
the subathon which I got because yeah I
wasn't even sleeping with her at night I
was sleeping I was comfortable sleeping
in front of the I mean no she wasn't
she's even gone to the camera she was by
herself but she's not really comfortable
to sleep on the cat oh yeah she wouldn't
have wanted to come yeah yeah of course
yeah that'd be weird that would be that
would be a little bit weird if we're
both sleeping together yeah it didn't
even come up get banned for seven days
Jack yeah it's only seven days so it's
been good because I think we both
understand the space pretty well do you
think you want uh marriage and kids one
day for sure yeah but it's kind of weird
in the at least where I am right now I
think part of being a streamer is you're
also like a like a you act like a
teenager and like in you just like go
live and then you yell and you play
video games all day and I think it's
it's hard to balance having a family
with that so I think it would be at a
point in my life where I am selling
bidets and I'm producing streams for
other people rather than I'm the person
in front of the camera at all times is
that the end goal I think so yeah uh and
that's why I started off brand which is
the company that I made with with my
business friends uh hrock Sands and Nick
Allen
that is just meant to make shows for
other people make productions for other
people uh because I I thought one day I
just like it was six months ago I was
like why do I have to be the guy in
front of the camera all the time like I
think I'm a decent host if I'm not the
best at this job I don't attract the
largest audience I'm not the like you
know most palatable I know how to make a
show and I know most streamers just like
being live 10 hours a day so they can
make money but won't put the effort in
and the work in in the hours in a day to
actually make a show so why did I do
that work for them why don't I get
funding for it why didn't I sell on it
take a larger cut from it and then just
produce it have them
um create their like greatest thing they
will do that year in terms of viewership
and and like critical Acclaim and uh and
and just be behind the camera what do
you mean by a show I think like
as opposed to an average stream right so
like most streams is just like dude
behind camera and there's not really a
way to build upon that and oftentimes
when you do it feels inauthentic like if
you have an insane setup uh with like
you know the five cameras it's too
professional and and it and it it's hard
to relate to the person behind that but
it the meta and the thing that has been
succeeding a lot for for streams is a
large scale production so I don't know
if you know the Spanish streamer eBay
but he does these large Productions very
frequently he has a huge team in Spain
and he got uh I think three million live
concurrent viewers on a boxing event he
ran which is the record for the most
viewers on any live stream in these
events you can think of them in the same
way as Mr BEAST's uh loss leader
almost assuredly it's a huge cost to run
this and it'd be much cheaper and he'd
make much more money if he just sat
behind a camera and his room playing
Minecraft but they bring in so many new
eyes that then his daily streams get a
lot more views and he'll do a lot of
these at a very high rate uh and so I've
run a couple of these like I did a a
Jeopardy clone called Mogul money yeah
and it got 150 000 viewers live and we
had an in-person audience of 6500 people
uh and it was it was probably like the
greatest live streaming event I've done
to date and and it lost money but it
will funnel in people for live streams
in the future wasn't that the one where
a sponsor backed out wasn't that the
reason why it was a loss like you would
have made money had it not been for that
I think so I we we definitely didn't
hold back on spending like I I booked
the venue for an extra rehearsal day
which cost 75k and I think if I hadn't
bought that we we probably even would
have broke even
um but yeah that was that was the
biggest one is that coinbase was our
sponsor and then crypto crashed and then
they just pulled out of all verbal
agreements because they just couldn't
they couldn't pay for it anymore right
uh so yeah events should make money
usually the first ones don't because
like it's proof of concept brands are
very uh risk-averse uh but after doing
like that one if I do another one I know
that will probably make one now how do
you balance that between I think more of
like an amateurish take which could do
better because it feels more relatable
like when I see big shows like that I
appreciate all the work and the
production that goes on but then I think
it it feels less like I'm there sitting
in the room because of how produced if
it feels like I'm watching a TV show
right how do you find the balance
between that I think it's always
important to make it feel like an event
that you cannot miss that that has that
urgency that you were there to see live
and it doesn't necessarily need that
one-on-one feeling as if you're watching
a friend behind a camera as long as it
feels like something that was worth your
time to watch so like in December
remember I'm running a chess boxing
event and I've lined up about
seven to nine matches we'll see how many
we get at the end of it uh and I think
like that's an event that you need to
watch live because if you don't you're
gonna hear who won on Twitter you're
gonna see who won on Twitter whatever it
is and it will feel a lot less uh
rewarding to watch the Vaude of it
what's chess boxing the coolest sport
ever dude what it is one round of Chess
and then you switch for one round of
boxing and you alternate until somebody
wins by Checkmate or knockout are you
serious wait wait what so it's just two
people going back and forth yeah wait
one round of Chess yeah you play two
minutes of Chess and then after the
chess portion you switch you you do
boxing for 90 seconds you switch back to
chess how do you do boxing for 90
seconds and like put the gloves on and
have that be
okay so for the boxing specifically for
chess you you have one glove on you're
wrapped up and then the other one is
wrapped but you have one glove off and
then you have to choose your your chest
hand and then you play chess with that
hand and then they you have like a like
a 30 second we'll have a trainer come
out put the glove on make sure you're
good to go have the referee clear
everything and then they box for 90
seconds what if it's like 10 Rounds that
people have to go there's a maximum so
the chest is a timed chest it's gonna be
like five uh minutes of chess with zero
seconds added per move so you will
guaranteed lose by time uh if you are
not you know moving quickly enough now
my thought is with the boxing removing
the glove is a big deal yeah
um have you thought about the timing it
would that it would take between like
playing a round of chat like I'm
guessing it's probably 10 minutes to for
someone to sign off on that glove to
make sure it's no so just boxing's a
real sport like it's a sanctioned sport
there's associations in almost every
single state and they do this
professionally and so the the turnaround
time is actually a lot faster than you
think
um to sign off on it it's about 30
seconds when it's functioning at its
best
because it's only one glove you need to
have on and you keep the wraps on who is
going to be boxing could you could you
reveal any names give me give us some so
an
a thought about doing it but I really
want to host the event and I want to be
commentating the events and I think if I
had a fight that day and then I had to
switch from host to fighting
that'd be impossible yeah I agree so I I
haven't been able to pull this together
this is the last piece of the puzzle
that I'm missing but I want to slap box
someone which is I don't know if you've
ever seen most criticals videos on this
it's a real thing it's mostly like
Eastern European sport but you just have
two men you huge Burly men and they
stand there they're not allowed to move
and then another person across from them
slaps them and you just keep going back
and forth until someone quits or passes
out I I've seen it I don't get the point
am I the only one who just I I don't
what's the point of being in Pain
Olympics it's all content baby come on
man slaps man in the face man falls
that's fun to watch is it a sport or is
it just like entertaining sport like
there's an actual competition I've seen
like the crowds it generates but I so
these movies don't get it slap box a
slap chest boxing so we would slap each
other then make a move slap each other
make a move when is this gonna be uh
live when can people see December 11th
we have the Galen Center which is like
where USC does their basketball games
and it's you know we're trying to get a
crowd of like 10K out and uh and just
make it real hot I would go to that that
should be fun yeah
yeah USC yeah okay cool yeah I'd go to
that yeah I'd go that'd be fun I would
love to go as like a spectator and watch
but there's a lot of training that goes
on for that oh yeah yeah we've they've
been training for like most everyone at
least the past two maybe three months
it's been like five six months of lead
time which isn't the most in the world
honestly but at least everybody started
with the same like totally amateur yeah
knowledge of boxing you did it yeah I
started with six I had six months yeah
but I really was serious about it for
four okay for those six months what's
serious like how often were you going
three to four times a week for an hour
but I should have sparred more uh the
the last month I started sparring but I
only did a few times and I should have
been doing sparring I don't know after
two months of doing it right and just
like you know light rounds just just to
get used to it but I that was my one
regret is not doing that more because
it's is it jarring to get punched and
that's like you need to get accustomed
to that yeah that would that was where I
feel like I uh I could have improved
because once I got hit in the head I've
never been hit in the head like that
before right uh because when I when
you're wearing the headgear it's a
bigger Target but it's not so like crazy
and when you're when you're doing a uh
you know sparring it's not quite the
same intensity with like people around
but yeah when you're hitting the head
it's so weird it's it's uh kind of like
imagine like blinking for like a split
second things just go and then come back
it doesn't hurt which is strange I
thought it would hurt yeah but it's just
that weird like out back in and it takes
you like a few seconds to just get your
bearings and be like all right I'm
standing here this is what's going on
but you don't have that time it's like
you have a split second and then at
least for me I got hit once kind of went
out came back in it was like
came back thinking for a split second
like oh that was and then boom happens
again so that's something that I think
you need to get used to like yeah you
can instinctually in that feeling when
you know you're going out yeah just put
your guard up yeah yeah that makes sense
to me and I also think it should be
better because of the extra break time
in between rounds
I expect everyone will become pretty
fresh and the guard will be you know
you'll be you're it's not gonna your
hands are gonna be heavy you know you're
gonna be able to lift up the gloves uh
because you have two and a half minutes
in between each round
um so
you know I'm hoping everyone comes out
of it yeah I think that break that two
and a half minutes is gonna set people
up to be really energized when they come
back in so each round is going to be
full intensity yeah because what
happened like even like the idubbbz
fights at the end of it they're just
cooked yeah which is like yeah it's like
a cardio thing and so I think that break
is gonna make it more casual but also
make everyone feel a little bit better
doing it yeah it was weird watching
Logan fight Mayweather and I remember
round like five or six or I forget how
many I think they went eight rounds or
maybe it was nine yeah I remember like
round five like Mayweather seemed like
he was just doing just fine but Logan
was tired yeah and I'm thinking oh
that's easy why is he tired I don't get
it but oh man you're like end of round
one and you're just winded you you can't
explain it's like running as fast as you
can without a break for three minutes
and then expecting you to be like I
still have energy after that it's insane
yeah the time's so short so I think
people's expectations are you'd you'd be
fine but no like if you just actually I
went to one boxing training they met us
through jumping jacks for three minutes
yeah it was cooked yeah that's not even
boxing I was just doing jumping jacks
well I couldn't feel my calves the next
day I was like okay I get it I get it
you can Tire yourself out real quick a
lot of it too is mental it's the
thinking through what are they gonna do
it's your mind racing at the same time
that you're you know physically exerting
yourself right I think that's what it is
I think it's the combination of the two
yeah yeah so that's that's the uh that's
the next event I'm pretty excited for it
and so how does that work uh money wise
do you have sponsors covering it are you
selling tickets is there an expected Roi
you're looking to break even is it
pay-per-view no it'll be totally uh I
want it to be my most viewed stream Ever
So currently that's like 205 000 which
was the end of the subathon uh
concurrent viewers and I and I'd like
for this to be the most so it's not
going to be pay-per-view because I think
pay-per-view is also like yeah maybe you
pull a million bucks you know maybe two
million dollars in in like sales but I I
don't think that's worth the the loss in
like cultural momentum by creating
something that people care about and
watch and talk about uh so the main way
that I'm hoping to make money is ticket
sales and sponsors I don't really know I
don't I don't think I have
already spent about half a million just
for all the people who are competing in
it uh just paying them making sure that
they're covered for all their boxing
time and food
um because that's not cheap and so I I'm
not exactly sure where this will come
down I mean it has a lot of seats so
maybe maybe it'll make money but I'm
also very happy if this breaks even and
I just have a really cool event yeah so
anything that you want to ask us any
other topics that you feel like you want
to cover yeah I got a question for you
guys uh what do you think and I don't
know if you have much knowledge on it on
the general Esports space
because it's kind of a money sink from
VCS
uh who all put money into it have you
looked into this at all I I'm always a
firm believer that if something's that
good you you'd keep it private um
right and it seems like a lot of the
IPOs are a way for investors to get
their money out uh and a way to
capitalize on all the work and I I do
think that from everyone I mean FaZe is
so recognizable and they built such a
huge brand but I kind of think if they
believed in themselves and they had the
longevity why do they need more money
because they they would have no problem
funding what they need to
well again I don't know the inner
workings of their business what
generally happens with most Esports
companies is they start somewhat small
somewhat manageable and then the
overhead becomes absurd because getting
like in a spot for for League of Legends
like an LCS spot it's like 40 million
dollars to buy that you know getting a
spot for like valorance like 15 million
what does that mean like to be in the
league like like think of it as like the
NBA like buying a team slot and if you
don't have that you're not a premier
team right so you need to earn it you
have to buy it you can have an amazing
roster of players and maybe a different
League or you know some minor doing some
minor league stuff but then the only
thing you can get out of that if you're
the owner of it is selling the players
so those the the game has really become
flipping players so just trying to get
talented players and then sell them to
bigger orgs or flipping spots in
professional teams uh in like um like
syndicated teams I forget the exact word
I'm looking for uh but like flipping
those is like generally how people are
making their money uh but outside of
that they're usually just burning
through investor money with insane
overhead and then eventually hoping to
go public or get another round
uh but pretty much everyone
is like just tanking money from the
Esports side yeah it sounds viable no it
doesn't sound sustainable it sounds like
it's a bit fatty yeah you know yeah for
sure is there's enough like teams that
have just poofed away right and just
disappeared I feel like FaZe also kind
of wanted to do like the Cloudy thing
which was like yeah if you go public
that's a ton of clout yeah but they were
the first they were the first to do it
right they were the first yeah yeah I I
think there's like a holding company
that's public that owns another Esports
org yeah uh but they're the first that's
like their their ticker is yeah I'm sure
it could be a lot of just a fad right
now but then over time it could develop
but I'm very much about like what's the
bottom line how much money does it make
let's not spend too much money let's
keep low overhead and keep this thing
running running slim or lean then let me
give you a little question I'm gonna
show you my Robin Hood account and tell
me what are good Investments and what
are bad Investments
yeah all right let's see all right so
you've gone from 261 down to 180 I mean
that's the market generally but internal
he's lost 25 000 in principle which
isn't like it's not bad I was up like 40
at one point what sucks is that you're
down five percent today uh nine almost
ten thousand dollars today that's not
that's not bad man let's go down yeah
are you using margin at all or no what
does that mean okay then that's uh
all right so you got a third of a
Bitcoin I think that's fine 6 000
Dogecoin yes I think that's a that's
fine I had I had some Dogecoin back in
the day I turned 100 into 17 000.
he sold at the peak yeah I lost it all
though oh yeah yeah I I had made a bid
off it and then just kept some just in
case yeah uh but I sold a lot of it it's
good probably good yeah uh I like your
stocks of art Microsoft really safe
Apple you can't go wrong with it Disney
I think is pretty good uh what do we got
here Coca-Cola got a Warren Buffett
stock there love Coke then we got
vertical Verizon yeah I'm not a huge fan
of Verizon but you know but I'm bitter I
invested in T-Mobile a while ago and
they did nothing how did you pick these
stocks uh so they're mostly things that
I believe in one things that somebody
told me to buy like Verizon was the
stock guy on Twitch who just told me to
buy Verizon so I did and then uh summer
memes like United Airlines I bought as a
joke because I had a running thing that
Airlines can only go up uh and then some
are random yolos that I found on random
websites yeah like app Harvest
that's a we I've never heard of this
company but you got uh
your average cost is 3.95 it's not bad
but at the peak this was a like thirty
dollars no yeah 33 stock and now it's
256. yeah you told me to buy it because
he said it was revolutionizing
agriculture I don't know and I bought it
because I like germa anytime it's
democratized or revolutionized I'm just
like no move on from that honestly it's
not that bad uh I invested in rocket
that's that's been a terrible that was a
terrible Wall Street bet YOLO it was
right oh either call or earnings call or
whatever and they're like it's gonna go
up and I bought it and it's down a lot
yeah uh Ford I really like Ford a lot
palantir has been awful that was one I
never got into another Wall Street bets
it turns out they're also an evil
company oh really I think so right I
don't think so I'll stop recording I
don't think it's bad
no I mean play money right yeah this is
yeah yeah so this is the so that's the
thing it's like if this if this were
your retirement account I would look at
that be like bro we gotta sell
everything just an index fund it keep
some cash on the sidelines but if this
is just like play money it doesn't
really matter and I would just look at
this like are these companies that you
believe in for the next five years and
if not I mean it doesn't hurt to take a
loss on them get a riot off and put that
money in a company that you do believe
in what does that mean uh if you sell
those at a loss you're able to sell
other Investments that you have as a
gain to cancel out so let's let's just
say you lost 100 Grand here but you made
100 Grand over here you could sell those
those winning investment that that
profit offset it with the loss oh no tax
whatsoever but it's the same amount of
money correct but it's like the net
change into is it just a a way to pull
out of a company you don't believe in
that you're losing on correct the the
benefit yeah yeah just just sell and
then re-buy back in it resets resets
your cost basis so that way like imagine
you sold this profitable stocks for you
know 100 000 Pro now you have to own tax
on that but you could offset that with
losing Investments like this and then
that way resets your cost basis on
whatever you want to buy so I've made a
[ __ ] ton on Amazon I believe in them
I've lost a [ __ ] ton on app Harvest I
don't believe in them yeah I sell both
it offsets and then I go right back to
Amazon and now your cost basis is higher
like imagine you're at uh let's just
let's just call it even numbers ten
dollars on Amazon now it's worth 20.
yeah uh that difference you're gonna
have to pay tax on that but by
offsetting it now all of a sudden your
tax basis is twenty dollars so if it
goes from 20 to 30 now you're only
paying tax on the ten dollars instead of
on the twenty dollars okay do you get
that Earth yeah I'm here I'm here yeah
are you guys are tap tax loophole
enjoyers I I enjoy no no maybe not a
loophole but you know within the tax
code there are there are some
opportunities there yeah is that not a
correct term not really I think loophole
has a negative connotation to it I I
think using the tax code as it's
intended is a great thing I guess I'm
referring to things like billionaires
borrowing and then borrowing their
borrowing and borrowing their borrowing
so they never have to pay capital gains
tax eventually no but the thing is
eventually they'll pay the capital gains
tax it goes somewhere now the the goal
is that you will pass away and your air
your heirs will inherit that at a
stepped up tax basis I think that's a
that's a loophole that they will close
at some point but right now it's totally
fine uh so I'm all for it I think for
most people it doesn't make sense to
borrow against assets to pay for things
but if you're in a category where
you could do that effectively then I
think it's okay what about the flying to
Puerto Rico living there for the 10
income tax and then sailing out of it uh
there are a lot of stipulations to doing
that that you have to follow uh I think
a lot of people just think blindly oh
I'll move to Puerto Rico for six months
in a day and I'll save all this tax
there's certain businesses that are
qualified to do that you have to comply
with that I think if you go through the
process uh why not but I think it's a
lot more involved than most people think
sure we just got a warehouse space and
uh we're gonna we're gonna do most of
the
work out of the warehouse for any like
uh shows or Productions that we have uh
and I'm excited to not be in my house
and work for my house because I've just
been doing that for four years you know
is it a Jimmy like he knows this too but
as soon as we saw his Warehouse we were
like oh my gosh having a place like this
I feel like could make us so much more
productive and give us so much more
freedom too right because right now our
podcast space like it's good we have
really high quality Equipment it looks
professional but at the same time the
room is Tiny like the room is
significantly smaller than this right
right and it's oh wow yeah I mean it's
like I mean is it like the blue yeah
it's probably like the blue yeah oh no
bigger probably probably where those
those things are I see yeah yeah I mean
it's it's a pretty small room for the
amount of like like production that
people walk in they're like wow I
thought this was so much bigger right
angle I mean it opens up so much more
freedom too you can have depth in your
podcast too which is kind of sick and
lots of stuff so we kind of have been
dabbling with that idea realistically
it's probably not gonna happen sure but
I'll be interesting to see how that
affects your work and if you find
yourself more productive leaving the
house and working somewhere else and
like being able to separate like home
life from work life yeah I think I'm
excited for that idea yeah I think that
that'll uh it'll change how I feel in my
house because I don't think I've felt
that in like ever you know really it's
kind of funny because I I've growing up
like I always figured I would do some
sort of nine to five at some point and
you dream to do the job where you can
work whenever you want but as soon as
you start doing that and especially if
you're working from home you strive to
have more structure and to be able to
effectively like clock in clock out oh
yeah and go in like but if you don't
have that that's all you want it's just
like The Grass Is Always Greener and
yeah schedules are so sick and when I
first went full time I was just going
live and then I would stay alive until
I'm tired and then I would go to bed and
I ended up having just a terrible
schedule and my life was just in
shambles yeah because I just didn't have
a time I had to show up so I just showed
up what I wanted and I said how long I
wanted and it was unhealthy I think a
lot of streamers uh are unhealthy
because they run that same what I was
doing uh before I switched to like a
more concrete schedule yeah I'm afraid I
would just never leave the office if if
this was something that wasn't at my
house yeah but in that same logic then
you are never mentally leaving the
office in your house correct but at
least I'm home sure yeah it's really
hard for me to turn my mind off yeah
it's it's
it's something I'm working on right but
yeah it's hard when you're in the focus
and just like you're in the moment it
I'm always thinking about it's always in
the back of my head especially if you're
able because like it's fine to think
about work when you're not at work but
if you're able to act on it too then
it's like well why don't I do it right
now why don't I just go do this thing
well I always have a task so like I'll
make maybe five things that I have to do
and my day doesn't end until those
things are done and so usually once I
finish up I'm good are you good at
making sure the task list isn't too big
or too small um yeah usually
yeah they'll rarely ever be something
that I put on that list I don't finish
like because I just got to get it done
so it'll get done are you good at that
I'm terrible at that like I'm always
like it's 8 A.M I'm like I'm do this
this this and it's so much stuff I can't
get it all done I'm not really a task
guy I know there's things that I have to
do I just have things that if I do them
I will feel accomplished for the day so
it's like I gotta work out uh that will
make me feel good I gotta
um post at least one video or stream and
so it's like I just do one business
thing so it's like if I do all three of
those I feel good yeah and it manifests
in different ways what do you have to do
for the rest of today today I have to uh
make a thumbnail for one video okay so I
can upload that video right after my
stream I have to figure out what I'm
gonna stream and then I gotta stream it
and if I do those then I feel good and
then I just play at least two League
Legends games so you're streaming today
Yeah final question Cool you said China
would fail in 13 days it hasn't I didn't
say 13 days what did I say it was uh 31
days 31 days well that was meant I don't
want to say in what what do you a lot of
the times what will we do for our
tongue-in-cheek yeah yeah that would
quote other people's right ridiculous
claims and you talk about said the
article within the video right so it's
not necessarily Graham's quote saying
that although he didn't necessarily
quotate it or whatever but yeah I think
I put in the thumbnail 29 days but that
was in reference to I think it was
Cascades Academy video which is 31 days
and I posted like a few days after him
yeah I think their economy is in the
crapper I think there's a lot of things
that they have to overcome but I
and all out collapse is is going to take
a lot
people would have to completely lose
faith in the system and there's nothing
stopping China from
bearing it and just trying to find a way
to you know snuff this out over here
print more money ease Paul there's so
many things that they could do to
prevent that from happening but long
term it's not looking good I think they
have a lot of potential though I mean if
they really wanted to like you know be
competitive they have a lot of areas
that I think they could improve and grow
at the same time and they could be a
major competitor but I think with their
current policies it's not going to
happen I feel like it's so easy for them
to switch it though because it's an
authoritarian regime that like if it's
not going well they can see that and
they can just do it they can just change
it it's not like something they have to
uh sway people on or convince companies
they just they can control whatever they
want to yeah so they have that Advantage
uh so I feel like they do spin it around
yeah and I think they will continue to
do that right but now I don't think
it'll collapse in three three exactly I
actually don't know how he came up with
that I'm thinking it's just you know a
title sort of deal it's like hey it
could be somewhere around here if you
put a time frame on something people uh
are more likely to click it for sure
there's like a sense of urgency yeah so
I'm guessing they're like what's gonna
happen in 30 on that 31st day that's
going to be different from the 30th day
I think it's also like a inherent
nationalism even for like Finance Bros
or or like uh business guys uh to like
be like okay China's failing yeah
because like for 10 years they hear that
China's gonna usurp America is the
number one economy so any anything
that's in contrast to that is like oh
interesting yeah I think a lot of people
worried Ray dalio came out with a
perspective of the changing world order
it's an Incredible video it's like an
hour long but it explains that the US
has been the reserve currency now uh
since then I think it was like the 1940s
or 50s is when it was officially
announced and no uh currency has been
the reserve for more than like a hundred
and something years and so according to
him there will be a point where maybe
something else takes over and so some
people were speculating well maybe it's
Bitcoin or cryptocurrency and you know
his argument was that China is growing
at such a fast pace that they could
outpace the US and they could but then
again you have to have trust in that
currency and right now there's not that
Universal trust that they would need but
I think a lot of people took an interest
than that and also everything happening
with evergrand and the fact that it's
something different and uh you know I
think just in general China's been in
the the media quite a bit and so people
take an interest in that yeah so when I
post those videos too it's interesting
to see because 80 of my audience is
us-based when I post one of those videos
it's only 60 US based so it's a lot
bigger reach and I think a lot more
people outside of the US that could
watch that video maybe learn something
from it yeah that makes sense to me
because I guess it's like especially if
you're not American orange China you
want to see like big world players
what's going on yeah feel in touch with
those that makes sense yeah but I try to
make videos that I think people would
want to see so if people are either
commenting on a certain topic or I see
certain topics doing well chances are
that's a topic that people are
interested in hearing about and then uh
from there I'm just happy to share my
perspective right I got one other
questions you said as soon as you passed
one million dollars and I'm assuming
what net worth liquid net worth uh yeah
that's when you finally calm down and
allowed yourself to add on to like uh
more expenses and overhead and stuff
like that as soon as you hit that
because I feel a similar philosophy I I
didn't set mine at one million I set
mine between two and four million it
used to be four now it's kind of two I'm
kind of like inching down right but as
soon as you hit that did you feel a
great wave of relief or did it not
really change anything you feel the same
no because it doesn't for me manifest by
the dollar amount I don't really know
where my finances are uh on a day-to-day
basis unless I like specifically look it
up I can tell how I'm doing financially
by seeing how well I'm doing like
professionally whether it's like my
viewership or with like my my like my
video views and things like that so you
know I think when I was starting to
average like a quarter million you know
views a video or when I reached like a
million subscribers on YouTube like
those are the things that I I'm more
able to look at and be like okay nice
and this is a theory that I have but as
soon as you let go of this like
Financial constraint you put on yourself
where you cared about it so much did you
actually see a positive Roi on that when
you allowed yourself to take on more
overhead and not worry so much about the
financial consequences of every single
business decision you make maybe it
spurred more creativity or something I
think it's a little different for me I
think I have a dumb brain in the sense
that I've always been I've never been
burdened financially or or felt stressed
financially uh you know I mean part of
that is we grew up middle class and we
were pretty comfortable and then uh you
know we had like a decent amount of
savings we had like a life insurance
policy my dad died so it's like money
money was not a big problem we had like
college was half paid for so I always
had this mentality it's that was like
yeah I'll make money whatever I do like
I don't think I need to be rich or I
will be rich but I'll always have enough
money to to live life uh and it's always
worked out and I always assumed
everything would work out and and I
think humans are way better at adjusting
to the life that they lead than they
realize and so it's like you know if I'm
if I if I'm at my poorest which was when
I first moved to Los Angeles I
immediately adjusted to that and I was
cool just eating you know peanut butter
sandwiches from Trader Joe's and then if
I'm at my richest I immediately adjusted
to that and I was like oh this is normal
and it is okay that I'm getting you know
in insane first class fights and I think
nothing of it so it's like there's never
a point where I had I'd thought about it
which I think is
a part of just the privilege of having
grown a middle class and do you think
that that inner confidence or even like
potentially could be considered naivety
worked in your face or do you think it
worked against you maybe like you gotta
like I gotta the time is now I gotta
grind I gotta do all this do you think
that perspective would have helped you
out more or do you think this confidence
yeah I think it helped a lot but it also
could be what's the word survivors uh oh
Survivor bias yeah survivorship bias
yeah so it's like in my mind yeah like
the idea that everything will always
work out has helped me because it
allowed me to throw myself going full
time with less money in the bank account
than I was comfortable with and hiring
people before I knew if I could even
afford the salaries
and it's all worked out and the business
has only grown every year uh by like you
know in in say numbers but that's also
because it's grown and it's succeeded
like there's a world where it's failed
and then I'm not in a podcast but
talking and kicking myself because I
spent it all and I could have done
better saving it but I've never had to
confront that because it hasn't happened
so it's it's hard for me to say if the
naivety helped or if I just got lucky
and now I don't have to worry about it
all right is there anything else that's
great you're good all right thank you ah